[музика]
у белхатові на півдні Польщі мешкає
близько 50 000 Людей багато Хто переїхав
сюди в 70-х роках через робочі місця які
тоді були створені на електростанції та
буровугільній шахті Сьогодні ці два
підприємства належать польській
енергетичній групі скорочено pge ектв ця
електростанція позаду мене викидає
найбільше парникових газів у всьому
Європейському Союзі це місце спричиняє
понад 30
тон вуглекислого газу це символ
прив'язаності Польщі до
вугілля 30 мльні тон шкідливого для
довкілля вуглекислого газу щороку лише
тут у белхатові Це більше ніж
викидається в атмосферу в цілій Ірландії
чи Словаччині грінпс хоче покласти цьому
край активісти роками протестують тут
проти забруднення
довкілляра Ми повинні відмовитися від
вугілля до 2030 року якщо ми дійсно хоче
реалізувати паризьку угоду ми бачимо що
зараз відбувається останніми роками
фактично уряд проспав ці роки в питанні
енергетичної
трансформації найбільша в Європі
електростанція що працює наборому
вугіллі забезпечує близько п'ятої
частини потреб Польщі в електроенергії
оператор pge оголосив що крок за кроком
згортатиме діяльність електростанції між
2030 і 2036 роками в рамках проголошеної
у Польщі мети поступово відмовитися від
вугілля поки що Польща не дотримується
кліматичної політики ЄС уряд запровадив
спеціальні правила і продовжує
субсидувати свої вугільні
електростанції польська енергетична
група відмовляється коментувати цю
ситуацію на камери відвідин
електростанції pge також уникає ймовірно
через шкідливий вплив на довкілля та
наслідки цього для місцевих жителів
те що ми спостерігаємо в районі
електростанції - це Невидимий ворог який
фактично вкорочує життя людям які там
живуть хоча сам пил може поширюватися і
на багато кілометрів він вкорочує життя
людям із більшою кількість інфарктів Та
інсультів попри шкоду для здоров'я
більшість мешканців белхатова все ще
проти закриття вугільної
електростанції нам не подобається що
закривають шахту тут багато робочих
місць економічна ситуація може
погіршитися без шахти балхатов був би
маленьким селом з 2сями
мешканців погано коли шахту закриють що
буде з людьми які сюди
переїхали Я боюся що нема плану що буде
з містом
далі Тут живе один з перших працівників
шахтилеон
войновський промисловість є невід'ємною
частиною його життя нині чоловік на
пенсії він охоче розповідає про свою
колишню
роботубрала на
групату тоді зібралася велика група
молодих інженерів з усієї
польщіже вони були сповнені ентузіазму
щодо цього проекту
проем бы в
настуазм до вуглевидобування чоловік
зберіг і до нині каже Це були найкращі
часи його життя до цього належать також
різні Шахтарські звичаї як приміром
місцеві фестивалі
пива мені сумно що Цей звичай зникне
коли закінчиться видобуток
вугілля мешканці белхатова поки що не
мають конкретних уявлень що з ними буде
далі після шахти одне нове велике
підприємство не зможе замінити вугільну
промисловість до того ж розвиток нового
бізнесу потребує
грошей щоб трансформація була успішною
необхідне бажання і співпраця усіх
сторін приватного сектору влади
громадських організацій тощо це зараз
обговорюється на багатьох
семінарах ми працюємо з молоддю з
бізнесменами з чиновниками з
громадськими організаціями що для х ливо
це краще транспортне сполучення кращий
зв'язок екологія довкілля А також
соціальна
згуртованість о рецій спочних проблема
теж у тому що десятиліттями робота у
вугільній промисловості оплачувалася
настільки добре що багато сімей у
белхатові могли дозволити собі кілька
автомобілів громадський транспорт майже
не використовувався і тому він
малорозвинений якщо нові компанії
захочуть переїхати до белхатова це має
змінитися якщо буде дуже добре
транспортне сполучення сюди прийдуть
інвестори які захочуть розмістити тут
свої заводи без комунікації та логістики
Ми не залучимо до роботи нових людей із
вузькоспеціалізованих галузей it
програмістів та інших хоча працівники
вугільної електростанції в белхатові
підтримують свою вугільну промисловість
вони аж ніяк не прив'язані до неї з
ідеологічних причин на багатьох дахах
їхніх будинків сонячні панелі не в
останню чергу завдяки державним
субсидіям Маріуш який продає сонячні
системи щороку подвоює свої
продажі у нас в регіоні майже кожен
інсталював таку систему кожен вважає що
для них це економічно вигідно белгатов
досі живе за рахунок найбільшої та
найбруднішої вугільної електростанції в
Європі Брюсель готовий допомогти щоб і
тут люди перейшли на кліматичну політику
ЄС
Y